As one of the original Uncanny X-Men back
in 1963, Cyclops had a ton of potential.
He's always been a key member of the mutant
squad, and his eyes can basically punch things,
so you'd think that would warrant a little
more respect around the Marvel Universe.
But comic book writers have done a pretty
great job of making Scott Summers Marvel's
most hated hero.
Let's take a look at the many ways this mutant
leader went from being kind of cool to kind
of a creep.
A lousy lover
Cyclops has a pretty awful history when it
comes to how he treats women, whether it's
his girlfriend, cloned wife, or just some
random swamp floozy he's trying to move on
with.
When he believes his longtime girlfriend,
Jean Grey, is dead from a volcanic explosion
in Uncanny X-Men #113, what does Scott do?
He gets over his grief pretty quick and starts
dating Marvel mainstay Colleen Wing.
Then, Cyclops straight-up dumps Wing once
he finds out that Jean is still alive, and
proposes in Uncanny X-Men #136… but Jean
dies again as the Dark Phoenix an issue later.
By issue #144, he's back at it with some lady
in Florida named Lee Forrester.
We'll chalk all that up to bad dating habits...but
it gets worse.
Cyclops marries his dead fiancee's clone,
Madelyne Pryor, in Uncanny X-Men #175.
And then he doesn't even treat his clone-wife
well.
It's eventually revealed that Pryor was a
tool in Mister Sinister's nefarious plans,
but well before that revelation, Cyclops had
already started hanging out with Jean Grey,
back from the dead for the hundredth time
after hatching from a weird ocean cocoon,
leaving his wife at home with a young Cable
in some cyborg Huggies.
Madelyne does get her sort-of revenge, hooking
up with Cyclops' brothers, becoming the Goblin
Queen, and raising some hell.
But when Madelyn dies later, Jean Grey actually
mourns harder than Scott does for his own
former wife and baby-mamma.
And we can't even get into which of these
Jean Greys were actually Jean Grey… and
which were actually the Phoenix in Jean Grey
form.
It gets complicated.
Anyway, even after ditching his family for
a back-from-the-dead-for-real Jean Grey, he
decides his new relationship is getting a
little tired.
Since, like, constant death and resurrection
isn't spicy enough.
Ever the loyal lover, Scott tries to liven
things up with some telepathic "therapy" from
Emma Frost... who's dressed up as Phoenix.
Since he's married to another immensely powerful
psychic, Jean quickly discovers his telepathic
tryst.
So what does Cyclops do?
He tries to weasel his way out of it, claiming
their liaisons didn't count because they weren't
physical.
And did we mention this?
Somehow he also found time to hook up with
Storm.
And who the heck is this?!
Maybe his eyes aren't the only part of his
body that he can't control.
Maybe he should invest in some ruby quartz
underwear.
And that is why you fail as husband material,
Mr. Summers.
Work over family
Being the unpaid leader of Charles Xavier's
mutant squad is not an easy job, especially
when humans mostly just hate you constantly.
Sometimes, an X-Man just wants to get married,
settle down, and spawn an omega-level mutant
or two.
Not Scott Summers, though.
Despite getting married to the aforementioned
Madelyne Pryor, Cyclops never left his super-villain
battling life behind, continually putting
the needs of the team before the needs of
his growing family.
If Cyclops was the sole mutant out there capable
of paying it forward, that'd be one thing.
But the X-Men and the Xavier Institute are
both overflowing with butt-kicking mutants.
Like Dummy.
And Beak.
And…
Glob Herman?
Anyway, even Storm confronted Scott at one
point over his dereliction of family duties.
His response?
Well, he challenged her to a duel, of course…
and he lost, even though Storm didn't use
her powers.
He built a murder squad
The mutant team known as X-Force was always
a bit rough around the edges, and often found
themselves at odds with both the X-Men and
the government, as well as the anti-mutant
groups they battled.
None of these problems were helped by Cyclops
being an extremely divisive leader.
In Uncanny X-Men #493, Scott Summers shows
some early signs of being a total fascist
by reorganizing the team to kill his own son,
Cable.
As if tracking and murdering your own kid
wasn't bad enough, he took the traumatized
teenage killing machine, X-23, on board.
He encouraged her murdery tendencies rather
than helping her reform, which went against
Wolverine's wishes.
And that, of course, earned him a good ol'
Logan punch to the face.
"Prove it."
"You're a d---."
And naturally, Cyclops disavows any knowledge
of X-Force's actions — until he's caught
red-handed by the rest of the X-Men.
And it's far from the last time Cyclops would
be a dangerous extremist.
He brought Phoenix back
Over the years, the X-Men have dealt with
more than their fair share of ridiculously
powerful beings.
But few of their foes matched the devastating
Phoenix Force.
Cyclops didn't just deal with this cosmic
firestorm on numerous occasions…he basically
married the woman who was possessed by it.
But despite enjoying far too much face time
with a creature that once destroyed an entire
populated world out of spite, Scott Summers
decided to welcome it back to Earth during
the Avengers vs. X-Men event.
The Phoenix Force breaks apart and chooses
to join with him and four fellow mutants.
But it turns out that just one part of the
Phoenix Force isn't enough, so he steals some
from his on-again, off-again girlfriend Emma
Frost, making himself nearly omnipotent.
Insane with power, Cyclops goes full-Dark
Phoenix and tries to kill pretty much everyone.
In the penultimate issue, the altruistic Professor
X tried to help Cyclops escape his cosmic
power trip.
But Scott declined, forcing Xavier to lay
the psychic smack-down on him.
Unfortunately, even an omega-level mutant
like Professor X is no match for the intergalactic
might of the Phoenix, and he's absolutely,
totally murdered by Cyclops.
All of this even before he's taken over by
the Phoenix Force, so he can't even really
blame the alien entity for being a jerkbag.
In the end, he's stripped of his powers, and
Scott winds up in prison, moaning about his
public image.
Because it's all about him, right?
From hero to radical
Merging himself with the corrupting Phoenix
Force, and having it literally punched out
of him, would probably be enough to make most
superheroes go cold turkey for a while.
But Cyclops never seems to learn his lesson.
Many readers agree that the downward spiral
began with 2000's X-Men #97, when he merged
with Apocalypse, but things only got worse
after the Phoenix thing.
In Avengers vs. X-Men: Consequences, Magneto
and his crew bust Cyclops out of super jail.
The X-Man then goes on to declare a mutant
revolution, threatening anyone and everyone
with the wrong end of an optic blast.
In the months following his "death" in Death
of X, Summers even inspires a crew of brutal
mutant thugs to carry on his genocidal uprising,
a not-so-merry band that calls themselves
"The Ghosts of Cyclops."
You guys, Cyclops isn't just a jerk.
He's kind of a full-fledged war criminal.
And that includes an earlier incident from
Secret Invasion, where he intentionally infects
an invading force of Skrulls with the Legacy
virus, which is incredibly bad news, and had
the potential to spread just about everywhere,
very quickly.
Aren't there, like, laws about this kind of
thing?
He incited war from beyond the grave
When Cyclops discovers that a weird fog has
killed the mutants on Muir island during the
Death of X storyline, including Multiple Man
Jamie Madrox, fingers are immediately pointed
at The Inhumans, and their transformative
"Terrigen mists."
In an effort to destroy the mutant-blighting
mists, Cyclops recruits a small army, including
a chemical whiz kid named Alchemy who pretty
much wants nothing to do with a mutant war,
and ends up getting killed while neutralizing
just one of a few of the toxic fart clouds.
At the end of the battle, Cyclops is killed
by Black Bolt's ridiculous singing voice,
becoming a martyr for everything wrong with
the pro-mutant cause.
Except Cyclops wasn't even alive at the time.
He was killed by the mutant plague before
the first issue even ended, and from then
on, he was only a deranged psychic projection
created by Emma Frost.
Sadly, dead men have no PR departments, so
it's easy to understand why so many people
ended up hating Cyclops.
But his worst crime of all?
He's named Cyclops….
And he has two eyes.
What a freakin' liar.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!